excited to be here feel free to
interruptive questions anytime
so today maybe ambitiously maybe a
little lack of humility i want to
explore the question of how can we trust
machine learning
and as anthony mentioned i joined
stanford about a year ago and in the
process i had to share all my teaching
evaluations for all the classes i taught
over the last
15 plus years
and
i strategically hid this one
it says professor gastrin i'm very
disappointed in your class
i thought machine learning was going to
be magic
but it's just math
and i call this the math myth of machine
learning circa 2008 when i got that
teaching evaluation and there we thought
that you could start with some data you
do some machine learning
magic or math
and you end up with profit which at the
time meant showing that my curve was
better than your curve
and then writing a paper at top
conference about it
now
this seems all well and good but there
must be some
magic in machine learning i mean we're
making a huge difference in the world
from
solving games that have never been
solved before to self-driving cars
and living a healthier day using devices
they use machine learning in ai
now to me the magic in machine learning
is what happens in the spaces
between the math
that is
how you define the problem how you
collect or clean or sell set up your
data how you define or choose your model
how you integrate that into an overall
system how you deploy the system and how
you evaluate to measure it
along the way
there's math in this
but the typical math that we think about
is a small component of an overall
system
and each step of the system is filled
with complex human decisions
that are getting harder and harder
because this machine learning is
becoming more and more of a part of
every decision that we make
and the systems are getting more and
more complex
it's important to step back and ask the
question
how can we even trust
machine learning
and one way to think about this is to
step back further and review the
question of how do we trust how do
humans trust
and i love the seminal work
by
tom and all
that looked at medicine and said that if
you have trust in your provider say your
doctor you have increased adherence to
the treatment
you continue with the provider longer
but if you don't have trust you don't
seek care you don't seek preventive care
you don't take surgical care
and this leads to
detriment in the long run
so
they define three areas
of trust
technical competency
does my provider does my doctor know
what they're doing
interpersonal competency do you
communicate well with me
about what they're doing
and the third one is agency do they have
my best interests in mind
and so inspired by this and the work
that we've been doing
in machine learning i've been asking
myself what are the core principles of
trust
in machine learning or ai
and here
i'm thinking about trust for whom
so
can i as a developer trust the things
that i'm building
if you're using what i built for you can
you trust what i built
and then as a society or as a community
can we trust over building are we doing
the right thing
for humanity in the long term these are
big questions
and today i'll focus a little bit on the
first question
can i trust what i'm building
and i'm proposing three
principles of trust inspired by
all the research has been done in the
area more generally with humans
first one is clarity second is
competence and the third one is
alignment
so
clarity to start is really the property
of being well understood of
communicating well
with each other
so to explore this
as a machine learning engineer
things are pretty simple you give me a
function f
i'll optimize it the best i can i'll
stay up all night i'll forget to eat but
f is going to be as big as possible
but the problem here
with trust
is have i picked the right f
have i figured out the right problem
that i'm trying to solve
so let's do
a little user study
uh based on a much bigger user study
that we did some years ago
and this was part of the university of
washington still
and
the mascot for the university is a husky
so every time there's a game
we brought a husky to the stadium
the real problem
is that if we by mistake brought a wolf
then thousands of people might die
you might think this is a funny example
but it's real
so we got together
with the senior leadership of the
university
and we decided the best way to solve
this problem is to build a neural
network that would predict
if it was a husky or a dot or a or a
wolf that came to the stadium
and as a community we decided 95
accuracy was the best possible what was
that was the right metric for us
in other words we decided if one in 20
games thousands of people died that's
okay
that's an acceptable risk
and so
my question to you is i have a model it
meets the requirements the safety
requirements they're defined for this
problem
do you trust this model
raise your hand if you trust the model
meets the requirement
clark does not trust them all
raise your hand if you don't trust the
model
if you don't trust the model is it
because you don't trust me
raise your hand
raise your hand don't trust me thank you
you don't trust my machine learning but
why
you meet the requirements
i'm sure you learned
in this class that you know you set up
some safety levels you might have
multiple metrics you meet those metrics
and you're ready to deploy
yeah
i'm not sure if this is
like sensitivity versus specificity i i
wouldn't summarize with just accuracy as
my trick
makes a good point
um
this is not the right metric
but the senior leadership of the
university decided that this is the
right metric
so
one of the questions is is this the
right metric and we'll talk a little bit
about it in the third section of the
talk
but even before then if you pick the
right metric even if you meet it
it might worry that you're not measuring
the right thing
so in this case
what uh my student marco hibedo did was
try to come up with a method to try to
understand why a machine learning model
makes a particular prediction
and so
what you're seeing
here in this next slide
is the prediction
the image and the prediction made which
was a husky and the parts of the image
that the model thought were important
this approach thought were important to
make this prediction
and i'm going to show you examples
from predictions of wolf
and
husky and what do you notice
yes
well i read the line paper so i know
it's
you know the answer so you already know
um it's looking for snow
and remember that at the end of the
quarter
but it's correct
um if you see here
i don't i haven't built
a wolf detector
i built a very deep and fancy snow
detector
in other words there was this spurious
correlation between
wolf and snow whenever there was a
picture of wolf most typically was in
snow that was giving us the high
accuracy and it doesn't snow very often
in seattle so it's unlikely that when
the the
animal mascot will come in there'll be
snow to help us ground the predictions
of wolf
so
if socrates via plato said
an examined life is not worth living
i say that marco would say an unexamined
model
is not worth using
so part of this
of clarity
is about
this property the quality of being
easily understood the quality of
examining
why you're making a particular decision
and whether you're doing this for the
right reasons
and as
we thought about this the first way
we've approached this is through clarity
v-interpretability
so interpretability is about giving
humans a mental model of the behavior of
machine learning models
so
if you might use a simple model like a
shallow decision tree it's very easy to
get a mental model of what's happening
but the problem is this model might not
be particularly accurate
so you can make decision tree bigger
now it's a little harder to interpret it
a lot of if and then roles
and it's a little more accurate
and there's a trade-off
and there's been some field of study of
trying to find more accurate
interpretable models
but the problem is that real world use
cases and superhuman ai
the focus on accuracy
tends to
leave us with a complete lack of
interpretability
and the question we approach from that
original work
which has led
to thousands of works in this area
is to ask can we provide some
transparency or interpretation
to
even the most accurate state-of-the-art
models
so
our
first endeavor said
let's
ignore the internal structure of the
model consider a black box
so we can
examine any state-of-the-art model
we can compare existing models and
future models and models from different
classes
and so in the first paper which you
mentioned lime well the the
insight was if you take a prediction
it might be very complicated in terms of
what the decision space looks like but
if you zoom in around the prediction and
if you zoom in some more
the space might look simpler
or locally linear
so can we fit a simple model
around each prediction that helps us
explain what's happening
so
if you take this confusing image and you
give it to image classifier
now we can interpret its behavior
can say it predicts a
electric guitar with probability 0.32
and then it's looking at this part of
the image
it's predicting it's an acoustic guitar
when it looks at this part of the image
and
a labrador when it's looking at this
part of the image
and thus gives us some sense
of what grounding we have
for the predictions
now if we go back to this user study
that we did together thank you for
signing the release form when you came
in by the way
and we we made it much more formal and
we worked with
27 subjects
before seeing explanations
about 60 percent of subject subjects
didn't trust the model
because none of them trusted me
and about uh
40 percent
had the snow inside
after seeing the explanations
26 out of 27 no longer trusted the model
so 25 verticals have no longer trusted
model
and 26 out of 27
had the snow inside
so the question i always ask myself is
who is that person
who had the snow inside and still
trusted the model
but as you can see by providing
explanations and an ability to
interrogate a model better you can
discover for example spurious
correlations in the data they're
impacting the behavior of the system
so really
the first part here is to try to provide
some transparency to give humans a
mental model of the behavior of a system
and lyme was the first endeavor in this
space and
assumed this locally linear behavior
there's been a lot of
follow-on work with a lot of different
assumptions in algorithms
one little example
i'd like to give you just to
show an alternative here is what we call
anchors this is about finding sufficient
conditions for a prediction in other
words if i were to move
the input anywhere in this box i will
still make the same prediction
so let me show you an example of that
for this prediction
in image classification
i always predict a beagle
if i fix this areas of the image no
matter what happens to the rest
now take another task which is the
visual question answering task it's
really cool you give me this image and
you ask what's a mustache made of it
says banana that's really impressive
or how many bananas are there in the
picture and it says two which is also
really impressive
but if you look at the anchors the
sufficient conditions for prediction
for the first question
is the word what
and for the second question
is the word many in other words any
question with the word what gets
answered banana
like what's the ground made of banana
what was the head of the u.s banana and
so on any question of the word many gets
the answer too like how many people in
the picture
two
how many is too many
obviously too
and so these notions
of
anchors interpretability help us
understand brittleness in the system
that you normally would not detect with
standard test procedures
so clarity can help
machine
can help machine learning help humans
make more informed decisions too
so here's a great example that i'm not i
was not involved in
where they're using similar kinds of
explanations in the operating room
to
detect when the oxygen levels go too low
so hypoxemia and not just providing a
prediction but providing predictions
plus explanations
helped
doctors be more effective
in their efforts
so that's
the
clarity
area trust is competence
a competence
is about having sufficient skill
or knowledge
for a particular duty or in a particular
respect
so sufficient skill for a particular
duty in machine learning
is about evaluation
does this model have the skills we're
hoping for
now
in 2008 this was very simple
i showed that my curve was better than
your curve on a benchmark data set and
that was sufficient skill to get my
paper published
but
even this notion of a test set is not
even practice
in practice
data is changing all the time
you have sometimes little insight on how
the system might behave in the real
world based on the training that you do
offline so benchmark data sets and test
data sets at best
a
weak proxy on what's going to happen in
the real world
and so to me we need to rethink how we
evaluate these models in practical
settings and learn from software
engineering where we do things like
failure analysis and more systematic
testing
of
software
so
what does that mean let me just give you
a couple examples in terms of failure
analysis one of the tasks that we looked
at is can you perturb the input
adversarially in a way that will change
the prediction
so there's been some work in this area
for example you give me this image and
the model predicts a panda you can add
some imperceptible noise
and now it predicts a given of high
confidence
now this is
really interesting work
but
this is more for like an adversarial
attack setting maybe for security
but it's not the kind of noise that you
typically see in the real world
our question was
what kinds of noises or perturbations
are natural that really will break the
model so let me give you a couple
examples of that so again visual
question answering i give you this
emergency
what type of roadside they show and it
says a stop sign or i give you this
paragraph and ask how long is the rhine
and it says 1 230 kilometers long
now here are some small perturbations so
for the first question i
changed it from what type of roadside is
shown so which type
of roadside
is shown
and now it's do not enter
and i change the second question from
how long is the rhine to how long is the
rhine
by adding an extra question mark and
it's now 1 million and 50 000 long
and so this is the kind of natural
variability you see in language
that is really breaking the model
so we asked ourselves and this is also
marco's work uh how can we find
semantically equivalent adversarial
examples
and we approach this is by using
paraphrasing models to perturb the input
but retain the semantics and then figure
out which ones would break the behavior
of the model
so let me show you an example that
again visual question answering
give me this image i ask what color is
the tray
and the model says pink which is pretty
impressive
but i start paraphrasing it
for example i ask what color is the tray
of a british accent and it's now green
or which color is a tray
and is now green
so these are natural variabilities that
are semantically uh very similar
but they lead to changes in prediction
and this is a problem typically a
problem in terms of coverage of your
data and so detecting it lets you do
nice things so for example you could do
data augmentation
and if you do that
in very simple ways you can
significantly increase
the robust model once you discover
these issues
so machinery models are prone to bugs
and really need to find semantically
meaningful ways to discover these issues
test for them and improve the behavior
of models
but really how do we know
when we're ready ready to deploy
this is a big question in general
and i think we need to test models more
systematically like with that software
so
inspired by software
testing approaches
we came up with this methodology we call
checklist
which
it's pretty simple so let me give you an
example
so let's say you have an input sentence
like easily the best airline in seattle
actually i should change it to is it the
best airline in san francisco
and i give it to a sentiment classifier
and it says it's a positive
neutral or negative sentence very simple
task
how do we test that
if we're software engineers
we start from testing small units of
behavior
so for example in nlp you might have
different vocabulary named entities
negations and so on
so what checklist does is a methodology
for creating tests
along different categories like this
and
based on the
skill set that you want the model to
have you can get some checks and crosses
and decide when you're ready to deploy
now let me show you a couple examples of
tests and what happens
the first one is medium functionality
test this is kind of no-brainer
you expect everything to work just fine
so for example in sentiment analysis i
give you a positive sentence
it should be positive like or a negative
sentence like i despise that aircraft it
should be negative
another one is negation
so i gave you
a
negated neutral sentence and it should
be
neutral so this is not an international
flight
now if you generate simple tests like
this
and you give it to public apis
or state-of-the-art models
they fail at rates of up to 15 percent
even though they're very simple tests
or with negation they can fill a rate
set to 54
this second kinds of tests you can
imagine are metamorphic or perturbation
like base tests so for example um
if you have an input
that has a location like i'm taking a
flight to chicago and now you change
your flight to dallas maybe you have
feelings about dallas versus chicago but
in general the sentiment should stay the
same
nonetheless
state-of-the-art models and public apis
fail at rates of up to 20 percent when
you do perturbations like this
or
finally you can imagine changing
sentences changing the direction so for
example if you have a positive sentence
you add another positive sentence you
shouldn't get more negative
but despite that simple perturbations
like this
cause models to fail rates of up to 34
and these are models that people are
paying money for in public in public
clouds
so what it says to me
is
we haven't had a systematic way to
evaluate these models before we ship
them
and what checklist does is a methodology
and a tool to make it easy to detect
and build tests like this
and we did a user study
on with engineers that work on
a real problem like this
and
using the methodology and the tool
they're able to generate more tests
more test cases per test
and detect more mission critical bugs on
the system is already applied
in a short period of time
so competence
is this really property of having
sufficient skill
for the task at hand
and is the second anchor pillar
of the three principles of trust here
the third one which is the most complex
one
is alignment
so alignment
is really about having a state of
agreement of cooperation
between peoples or parties for common
cause of viewpoint
and the key here is a common cause or
viewpoint does my ai does my system have
the same cause of viewpoint that i hope
to have
so again 2008
very simple we had totally aligned
principles we want to get a paper into
the conference
but these issues can get much more
significant
when you start building real world
systems and netflix articulated this
really well
so
they're recommending content for you all
the time
and they had this challenge in 2006
which was
really popular and really put a lot of
effort into recommender systems and the
idea here is you're given a data set of
movies and you had to create a model to
predict what rating a user would give to
a particular movie
this was extremely useful for them in a
sense there was a lot of work in
recommender systems
yet they didn't deploy this
in their actual systems
and the reason is this is not the metric
they care about in their business
the metric they really care about
is churn
what is the chance that next year you'll
cancel your netflix subscription
and predicting your rating
doesn't help me too much with respect to
children
based on a variety of methodologies they
discovered a metric that didn't make
sense
and it's binge watching
so if you click on something and you
binge watch it you're a lot less likely
to turn next year
and so
they decided to create a metric which is
to maximize the probability that you'll
click on something and watch it to the
end
and optimizing that was closer
to the business metric they cared about
now i call this the loss
metric gap
the loss function is where we optimize
machine learning the metric is what we
actually care about for the things we
build
now you could switch a loss function
like
increase the probability of binge
watching and get closer to the metric
that you care about churn
or you could try to find some other
smooth approximations of the metric you
care about and try to get closer to the
loss function
but the problem is that there are
typically multiple metrics that you care
about
they're complex and fundamentally as a
machine learning engineer you typically
don't own those metrics
it's often a product team that's
deciding how to evaluate the overall
system
and you don't see all of that or you
don't necessarily have access to all of
it
so it's a really complex process
so what we did
uh when i was still at apple is come up
with a simple methodology to solve this
problem to address this problem and the
idea here
was can we come up with a parametric
family of loss functions
that you can evaluate against the metric
that you really care about
during the training process as you're
optimizing the model parameters every so
often you go back and you re-evaluate
the metric you actually care about like
churn
and then you use that to update the
model parameters and get them
the metric the loss parameters and get
them a little closer to the metric you
care about
the simple procedure was very effective
but
this issue of loss metric gap is getting
more and more complex so for example you
think about foundation models or large
language models or the idea that we're
training these really complex models and
reusing them in many ways
now we have an even bigger gap because
we have a model that's been trained for
example with a language
model loss
which has some gap
to the prompting loss that you use which
has some graph to the metric that you
use so the bigger the more complex the
system becomes the harder it is
to align it with the behaviors they care
about
and
doing this is hard
but important
and in fact there isn't a single metric
you care about like we saw in checklist
there might be multiple metrics we care
about and we have to somehow figure out
how to trade off
between all of them
and that's even more complicated
an alignment
is about agreeing on how to balance the
different concerns
and we we got an uh example earlier we
talked about sensitivity versus
specificity that's a a different set of
concerns
and they can sometimes go against each
other
so let me show you a very simple example
of that
so
one of my teams at apple came up with
this feature for the watch where instead
of having to say an activation word for
the personal assistant you could just
use a gesture so you could say
what's the weather today
i don't know if i have internet
connection but
uh it is detected and it's thinking
and just based on the gesture it was
able to
evoke the personal assistant and this is
really interesting
and you have to think about what metrics
you care about
so for example false reject
is a misgesture
so i raised my arm
and it did not detect me
that's that's kind of a
a little bit of a problem but a false
accept
is a big problem this is when i'm giving
a talk i'm gesticulating a lot and being
latino and then suddenly siri speaks up
it's like
i didn't hear what you said it's like
you know you're so stupid
and the problem is i spend much more
time
gesticulating and talking then i do
evoking a personal assistant
and so
false accepts
are a much
bigger concern
so when you're thinking about a product
you have to think about the trade-offs
between the different criteria that
might arise
the way that we did that was we trained
a bunch of models
and we came up with
a set of product decisions so we're
gonna have less than one
false accept per week
so that's one time per week my
weird gestures evoke the personal system
try to make the false rejects as small
as possible
but even that simple trade-off
was really complex
and in reality
what we're trying to align is not that
just simple trade-off is all sorts of
values that you might care about
like the accuracy
of the system like false positives was
negative sensitivity specificity but but
more
as we've seen
machine learning can have a
disproportionate impact
on different populations around the
world
this has been discussed for example a
lot in recidivism
uh this recidivism setting where
black defendants were much more likely
to have predicted to be
uh committing a crime again than white
defendants
so
there might be many criteria you care
like in fairness there are multiple
criteria and there's a there was a for a
while a formula for writing papers we
say here's three criteria they all make
sense and here's an impossibility
theorem that says you can't satisfy them
all at the same time
now what that means is not that it's
it's something you give up on
but it is that you have to make complex
trade-offs that express
the value system
that you care about and today there's no
really good way to think about machine
learning as a multi-criteria
optimization problem and how these
trade-offs can be made
and every choice that you make
as a developer
every choice that you make when create
systems
impact
the world impact people and they have to
be aligned
before you're hoping for
so for example i often ask myself what
am i teaching my models
maybe i should ask you know what am i
teaching my kids so here's some time ago
my kids are watching a show that they
loved
and i hate
called paw patrol
in this show there's five puppies
uh six puppies they go on life-saving
missions
there's only one girl puppy skye
who is dressed in pink
and almost always in the sideline
watching while the other puppy saved the
day
this is not the kind of
model
that i want to share with my son or
daughter
and as we're experiencing more and more
of the world through devices
it's important to think about
how our values are aligned
and
again the data
in the choice of data is one of those
important decisions that defines the
behavioral machine learning model and
this is not a new problem
so
before digital photography
we use film so there was this plastic
canisters with a little thing inside you
might see this no
and you have to send it to lab to
develop
and get your prints
and the labs around the world and kodak
that was the biggest producer of the
time
had to make sure that the chemicals in
those labs they had different
temperatures and humidity and so on were
calibrated to give good pictures
the way they did that is they created
this scards
in the 40s and 50s
which they called shirley cards you can
see a bit of sexism there already too
and they're always a light-skinned
female model
they always used to calibrate the
pictures
and so what that meant is for
people with lighter skins
the photos look great
but if you had darker skins the photos
were overexposed
and you can really see that when you
have photos photographs with folks who
like their skin tones and darker skin
tones in the same image
and it wasn't until
the 80s and 90s
they started using cards
with folks with different skin tones in
order to calibrate chemicals
so this is an example
of how
uh diversity or representation the data
is really important
but it's not just about the data that we
collect and we use to train a model
every choice
that we make
in the development of a machine learning
system has to be aligned with the values
that we're hoping to exhibit in the
world
let me show you a final example here
machine translation
it's amazing with neural machine
translation it can translate between a
large number of languages
we can also be faced with very
significant images so for example if you
go from a non-gerund language like
english
to a gender language like latin language
for example portuguese
you can get
this kind of behavior the doctor called
the nurse gets translated to the male
doctor called the female nurse
which will perpetuate a number of
stereotypes
now the issue here is
in brazil today about 57
of the doctors identify as male
now the ratio
of doctors they identify as female is
increasing rapidly
but today if you do a hard translation
like this
anytime that more than 50
of the doctors are male
then you're gonna get a male translation
the male form
and so
even if we had infinite data
if we design a system this way we'll
always be
perpetuating the stereotype
so
even
in this setting
we have to think about alignment
as how we're going to represent our
values in every decision that we make
along the way
so stepping back
i think we need to think carefully about
where the principles of machine learning
they can help us address trust and
making trustworthy systems and i'm glad
you're here this course in discussing
this and my proposed framework is around
clarity competence and alignment
and with that
thank you anthony thanks for having me
and i'm happy to take some questions and
discussions
[Applause]
yes thank you for your talk i like your
animations um
i'm glad to serve yeah
could you talk about the interaction
between these three different um
categories like for example to what
degree do you think clarity helps with
alignment
that's a that's a really great point um
you know you'd think that you'd want to
create orthogonal access but the axes
are not necessarily orthogonal so for
example
i think they build on each other so to
understand alignment part of it is that
you want to evaluate competence along
multiple metrics that you care about
and part of evaluating competence or
understanding where the model is working
is not working and building trust
is the notions of clarity so to to me
these are more like layers that build on
each other
um so for example you asked about the
relationship between
clarity and alignment
i would like to be able to understand
who is being impacted by something or
if you're making trade-offs who is
benefiting and who is not
when something happens and you can think
about this
uh from a fairness perspective in terms
of group fairness so what groups or
populations let's say
um
blacks hispanics for example or typical
ones that are discussed in terms of race
are impacted by the decision models in a
disproportionate way compared to whites
but you also might want to ask about
individuals so how is the treatment that
you're getting
relate to the ones that everybody else
is getting in this class
is anthony being fair to you and can we
make that
more clear or transparent and so part of
that is about what values we want to
reflect in the system
thank you
for that question
others
yes
so you and your team did some of the
seminal work on explainability methods
uh and i forget what year exactly that
was but like
where have things gone since then what
are you most excited about in terms of
emerging algorithms and whatnot for
explainability yeah it's uh
i can tell you what i'm excited about
and i can tell you what i'm concerned
about
um so
what i'm excited about is that there's
been a tremendous amount of focus on
this and a number of different methods
or ways to think about explanation so
for example in lime explanations are
about what features in the input this is
called future importance
or feature attribution so what parts of
the input are important there's others
have
asked can we use examples or data points
to help explain the prediction some
folks ask can we use we're called
concepts so these are not
neither features nor data points these
are things like
uh when i predict zebras am i using the
fact that zebras have stripes
in order to make the prediction so
there's been a lot of exploration in
terms of
what kinds of modalities are important
for explanations there's been
great exploration in terms of
making these algorithms more robust and
faster and more scalable
some are model agnostic like we talked
about where you can see the model black
box some of them have been
opening up the box of the model and
using the
inside to help make these things better
or faster so all that is great work and
i'm very excited about it
i think that the
biggest fault but the biggest
concern i have
and i think you know we made a mistake
six years ago
that's been reproduced
often
which is
a lot of these methods go from the
explanations forward so they say
oh isn't it cool we can explain this way
isn't it cool i can have this other
notion explanation isn't cool that i can
make it faster
but almost none of them
start from the decision backwards
so what decision is a human making
like is a human deciding whether to
intervene on a patient or not is the
human deciding whether or not
to join
netflix you know what is the decisions
being made
and how does explanations how do
explanations support that decision
so one of the things i'm most interested
now
is to think about the decision-making
process so how do humans make decisions
and how can we make more informed
data-driven decisions
based on things like explanations and i
think that that's kind of the
open biggest open question today uh in
my opinion
yes um i guess this might remain beyond
your talk but in alignment you mentioned
that you know you have to figure out
trade house between values and i was
wondering when such a resolution is not
possible
um how do you reconciling so for example
you gave the machine translation example
right um with the fair way of
translating it be a female doctor and a
male nurse um or you know male doctor
female nurse like i guess in my view
there isn't truly a resolution by the
way um and what happens when
your values might be indirect contrast
so for example if netflix wants to make
sure that users binge watch their
content but users interests are perhaps
different
um
is there any way to kind of think about
resolving these things and i think it
also comes up quite a bit these days in
the tech world in the case of privacy
where companies and trust would be
different from the user's interests um
so yeah is there any way you could think
about that i
really appreciate your question so
thanks for bringing it up um
and i teach a class
on the ethics of ai and i see a couple
of the students here today so they're
getting a double header of of me on
these topics but one of the things that
we talk a lot in the class
is that
there's no right answer there's a lot of
nuances
and one of the problems is
as engineers
we're not trained to deal with nuances
like every homework that you have has
one right answer
there's a rubric
this day is an automated system to
evaluate your homework and you're done
and then when you leave here
when you leave stanford and get an
amazing job at whatever
job you want to take
you're going to have to deal with the
nuances of the real world
and as an educator
i feel like i failed that we failed to
help build up the muscle of trying to
lay out the trade-offs and the nuances
in this algorithms and so
the first thing
the the first step
you can think about this is a
mindfulness exercise the first step is
to
do what you're talking about can we
articulate the different perspectives
what are the different values where who
are the stakeholders where the different
interests
they're being represented
um can we understand what metrics
different people care about
and so on and part of
what we need to do is that exercise more
thoroughly as opposed to saying
i'm gonna pick lambda one plus lambda
two plus number three and be done
and so can we do that more thoroughly
and that's what a anathesis would do for
example one of the
folks who gave a lecture in the ethics
of air class methodist
um
rob rich who's a very
well known stanford professor
and
you know he jokes a lot that people come
to him and say oh you're the ethicist
come solve this ethical problem for me
like how do i deal with this machine
translation give me the answer
and he doesn't have the answer
like what he's very good at
is what ethicists turned out to be very
good at is articulating the perspectives
like helping you write down okay
this is one perspective and this is what
they care about it's another perspective
what they care about so there's that
process but ultimately as an engineer
you're gonna make one choice like you're
shipping a machine translation system
and you're going to pick an operating
point or a decision of how that's going
to go and so
what what i'm interested in is can we
help articulate the process of
trade-offs
can we understand if you make a choice
since you have to make one choice who is
impacted
so
who is going to benefit who's not going
to benefit can we articulate that can we
make that transparent or more
explainable in a way that you can
understand that and that happens all
over you mentioned privacy is a great
example of that and i've been involved
in very complex
privacy decisions that
um
that again there are no right answers
and you have to figure out what choices
to make so sorry i have not answered
your question just to say that there's
lots and lots and we have to be more
better at dealing with those
any other questions
yes uh in your in the section about
alignment um seems like you talked about
uh like aligning
loss and metrics that gap and um
kind of these these other like current
uh differences in how we deploy our
models how like we intend them to do you
think like i guess what are your hopes
for your research um thinking like
larger agi
general intelligence stuff
do you think things like adaptive loss
alignment or other algorithms like that
also translate to aligning superhuman ai
to human values broadly
well that's that's a big question so
um
agi before we go to agi i'm a big
believer in augmentation over
replacement so
in other words how can
a.i help us
um
be super humans let's say or you know do
things that we didn't think would be
able to do before and if you take that
perspective of things so ai for
as a tool for augmentation
um they can get better and better
alignment is incredibly important right
so
i think that that is uh that's something
that you know adapter loves element i
think is a
tiny step in this very big problem
because in our heads we have a set of
values we care about we don't even know
how to write them down
and so how do we help translate what's
in our head
to a behavior of a system an example i
use in the ethics of ai class
is a self-driving car
you're probably familiar with the
question of you know the trolley problem
like
do i
veer myself off a cliff
with a car or do i hit somebody in the
road but take a much simpler question
um
do i
drive on a windy road
fast to get there faster or do i take
more risks
or do i take a more conservative kind of
safer but slower pace
that's a hard decision
does
self-driving car dog call make that
decision for you like you step into the
car
and say
it decides to you know
drive slowly or drive fast or something
does it ask you to enter your
preferences in this
you know interface with lots of sliders
can you understand that
is there something in between
like what does that look like and and i
want to say that our or even for that
very simple example our values are not
aligned
like
and it depends it's contextual
if i have all my kids in my car
i might want to behave differently than
you know if by myself
my kids are going to college maybe i'll
behave different than if my kids are
young and depend on me i don't know
and so
uh
how do you how do you make this
complex context contextual decisions in
collaborative ai
um
human settings it's a it's a really hard
question and so i i'm very interested in
that and when you get to agi i don't
know what you mean by agi do you mean
agi is a human
um you know an entity that
is itself sentient and
uh is it has its own separate value
system or is it a reflection of our
value system and that's a that's a very
complex philosophical question too
hope that helps
all right let's thank carlos
[Applause]
you